just move the knight don't play c3 don't
play c3
oh my god
[Music]
the mud wig 5 up this is this is uh
this is for all the marbles asking
was asking the right questions um he was
interviewing five up on whether he uses
a bidet
i was gonna ask you danny do you use a
bidet
if there's a bidet available
okay correct answer i think ludwig would
approve they sped through this opening
i i love hosting shows i love hosting
shows with you because i feel like i'm
usually the one who asks people
questions that are out of left field and
inappropriate and you just take up you
you take the cake this is amazing what
do you mean what do you mean i ask
things that are inappropriate you
haven't even heard my best questions
okay one you know it's not inappropriate
to talk about hygiene or bidets or lack
of bidets but i just i just didn't see
it coming and that brings joy to me
um
good i'm glad you know my sister just
says i don't have a filter so i like the
way you put it more yeah
i i think it's like the engine says and
that's not a cop i think this is a very
equal position because yes he has the
backward pawn but he has a very natural
way to gain space
and
if ludwig hasn't seen it yet andrea
white has to go for this f4 e5 plan in
this structure this is actually a benoni
structure speaking of of the different
e4 and d5 versus d6 and c5 pawns and
white wants to do this
black wants to expand over here and and
try to undermine the center so
this is who who figures out the right
plan to gain space first is gonna be
better
fiveup has emerged out of nowhere as a
darkhorse to win the whole event and
when we had that first interview with
him a few days ago andrea i don't know i
don't know if you heard it but he said
he played in tournaments as a kid
no he's been super eager like since
early pogchamps he was always interested
he was always playing chess with his
friends on his free time like five of
and he's obviously a strategic
mastermind he blew up you know because
of how good he was that among us
yep
look at this he's highlighting rookie
5d5
he's still better here despite losing
the pawn
okay it's a little slow
ludwig accurately bringing the king in
right away
you don't want to do that he keeps going
in the chat
anna did the preparation succeed in the
game if you're in the chat
i have a feeling grand master robert has
told ludwig to play a scotch i don't
know that anna and five up were prepared
for ludwig's opening just guessing
i went up
now he's he's back to the rook i did he
probably could have just run the king to
e5 but looks like he finally finds rook
can you show i win i get that there and
i get to his peace force oh
the king and opponent ending
it's losing for love oh my goodness
oh no
the end game master has been outplayed
in his own game okay wait hold up let me
do this
if i go here not happy he doesn't even
know he goes here
if i go here
takes
here the square here
here
here here
okay that's fine
okay i was stressed out for a moment
because he can't he can't go in any of
these
like this is this is still just blocked
off for him
i know we've talked about croakies
obviously
he was rushed over here but he wants to
kill that before but i think we might be
looking at the new favorite to win
pogchamps for i'm not kidding
like yeah i am very impressed like even
against box box i don't know
his performance in this game just
completely even boosted my expectations
that i i knew he was good before
they're going to run the game report
look at accuracy on this
and five up played this was this was
expert level chess like no joke i mean
other than knight c3 there's like almost
very little room for concrete
improvement
and
they say experience wins championships
right and i think coming in we didn't
know as much about five up so we thought
blood was more experienced or box box
was more experienced but reality is
after that interview where he said he he
got to almost 1100 otb chess that's a
different level of experience than most
of our pogchamps
you know
kind of crowd has gotten and it look at
this i mean this is we accidentally have
a ring
to win it all
oh my goodness
yeah chad was saying maybe five up first
funding the finals which would be really
funny because uh they always play
against each other and they always train
together
yeah and i didn't even mention fundy
along with box box ludwig and and
croakies of course but see croakies is
gonna be one of those guys and this
isn't taking anything away from steven
in case he watches this like he's gonna
grind what he can now andrea but he's
never gonna get like the kind of
experience that five up had from like
playing for years right and what happens
in those critical moments when your
intuition has to take over is that is
that kind of experience and i'm looking
at this game by five up and i'm ready to
say we have a new favorite to win the
whole event that was that was probably
the best game crazy
big town big town hype town that's what
the cool kids say big town hype town
i'm so i'm so excited this is this is a
staunton gambit mainline theory and a
very common trap is black plays d5 here
and then white can take and win both
pawns with the check
because at the end of the line you fork
everyone i actually beat grand master
gabriel schwartzman in a blitz
tournament with the strap so grand
masters fall into this trap it's a
well-known trick nice
okay bishop before i like this i mean
one sled with castles here who
who is this position in favor for any
side here
um i still like white if five up can
play a move like queen to d3 which would
attack the pawn and reopen castles long
so
the problem with check is that now after
queen e7
you're d4 pawn
oh we took with the knight
literally again speeding a little bit
too much which seems like moments like
that where you're trading pieces you
don't need to think but
yeah he could slow down a little bit
he's got more time than he started with
takes
takes takes
night here
sure
[Music]
oh
check
[Music]
like
stupid
[Music]
yeah that's how okay i see the other way
was correct whereas a
on like that
if i go here
yeah we're used to seeing cutie
cinderella throw for content not five up
a very high quality game again not quite
the first one but these two guys are
are both gonna be super tough out tough
outs excuse me in pogchamps
[Music]
i'm back oh she's here
oh man the child was just saying that
they wish you were singing and they were
so upset that it was just me
okay and for the record it was not the
sponsored laptop that died it was my
streaming laptop what i missed
cut the rug what happened we
we did we we shook a leg we shook our
groove thing and ludwig is gonna he's
giving us tie breaks andrea
um
he's cleaning it up
he's uh cutting the cheese what were you
saying
as they say when they throw down
um cutting a leg
yeah shaking a leg cutting a rug busting
a move shaking his groove thing those
are all appropriate things to say
no it's still winning
some people in chat saying it's not it
is winning
oh yeah you could just hey what's going
on guys
it's fun here right
yeah but in the end it'll be stalemate
unless he loses the right tempo with the
knife who's the knight oh
yeah
that's crazy
[Music]
oh wait
if the king ran runs to the side of the
board with the knight and the pass pawn
there's actually still outside chances
at a draw for five up because the knight
if he plays king d5 here if you please
keep going
he can initiate
[Music]
oh god oh my god oh she did it
he finds him my goodness
wow
but he if he's gonna get a drone oh my
god he played k7 let him get a queen
with check
any other move is to draw
oh
frick
but this is still a super tough game to
win you have to bring the king over yeah
ludwig he does he know the technique i
don't know that he knows the technique
you have to bring the king over stop
moving the queen yep
you have to bring the king as soon as
the king is in front of the pawn and
he's not doing it he doesn't know he's
continues to check
this is a very critical game okay he's
figuring it
[Music]
out let's see
oh my god he's figuring it out on drake
i think he unlocked the pattern
he did it
he figured it out how did he just learn
how to win the sun game
that's impressive beautiful
[Music]
that is amazing maybe he did read that
end game manual this is now maybe that
was happening okay he doesn't see it but
queen eight's actually made on the board
i don't know if he's gonna see it
but
oh my goodness
wow
he's getting jiggy with it danny that
was incredible
suck my
ludwig gets white by the way because he
had a higher
cap score in the last game or something
like that the staff will remind me
okay yeah this is this is different
rather than c3 this is theory day
i mean
this is this is good for black actually
this is better for five up than than the
scotch that he got against ludwig in the
first game
okay but now there's
there's rookie seven he doesn't see it
he's not even looking down
would be the move here
okay this is good this is a really
really good trade because the bishop is
better than the knight in the end game
but it might be very hard to play black
here because if lovely plays h4 which he
did now all the pawns are on dark
squares i think i think this is easier
to play with the knight at this level
than with the bishop
yup he should play b6 oh he's gonna make
a trade but he misses the c5 in the end
what what oh
oh what yeah i don't understand why i
didn't just push b6 i'm gonna take this
yeah you can do that i messed up
um
oh he doesn't see his other bars falling
i go here
there you go just there
or where ludwig will get his edge in
matches he's very good in the faster
time controls right now all that winner
stays practice you're welcome ludwig
yeah even though he took quite a beating
got it just moved the knight don't play
c3 don't play c3
oh my god
no
i used to do that to me myself too don't
hit yourself also
i can't do that what made me so sad
oh my god
he was playing so well gg i just
wondered
oh you just take the pawn that would be
there he goes all right
yep he's blocking the bastard giving him
no chance and now
simple pawn push to the wind
push him
baby wow
don't cold kill her he's ruthless
not even going to let like i mean
look at him
look at him pre-moving his way to
victory oh what a flicks
let's sit on poor ludwig
[Music]
wow
what a match
well
i think we were crushing i imagine
right up until i was like oh right
i cannot take and defend this piece
live up how does it feel to win group a
honestly it feels super stressful i
don't even know how to process it it's
just i
i don't know how to feel yet at this
point it hasn't really hit but i'm
really happy
if they were
bottom line for me was they were just
super fun games oh you know what he had
great preparation had a great opening in
both games and the finals as well i
think i had him there for a moment but
uh just blended away my night and we'll
look to see what we can do in the
championship bracket
how do you feel that you lost a man who
doesn't use a bidet
i think he is i hate to use the word
subhuman so i never will but
a
peon at best but uh the game of chess i
have found through my years
uh equates to zero in real life
intelligence uh and you'll find that out
i can confirm if you have any
conversation with the grand master so
you know um i'm happy to take the l
today but he takes the l every time he
takes her
[Laughter]
five up
any response to the i mean
well i i don't really have a rebuttal of
that let's just say i've never
let's just say i haven't really been
presented the opportunity so i don't
know now i am kind of excited this
almost worked out for me in a way
because are you excited to play box box
box box gonna be hard he's the actual
first person who ever beat me in any
podcast event ever i don't think i know
that
uh and so box box would be really hard
but i do think
that fundy is the strongest person in
the field right now
uh i think he has put every single point
of effort into winning this event box
box uh
not so much
um
i i just think that's honest i don't
think i think box box has played in
other events you know this is not like
if this is your first pog chance it's
like do or die for you box box been here
i've been here and so i think it'll be a
really great match i'm excited to play
him but i'm excited that i'm not on
fundy's side of the bracket uh i saw you
guys play six games and you'll need your
one and six chance if you get to him if
you beat zap then well cause that's
gonna be tough
[Music]
you